hello I'm Julia King from Aston
University in the United Kingdom and I'm
on the automotive Council and we've been
having a very lively debate and we've
come down to three areas where we are
taking things forward and one is in
trying to put together a whole economy
framework probably based on the work of
the International Energy Agency to which
we would try and get some agreement from
the automotive industry about where
we're trying to get to in 2050 that's a
that's really quite a challenging
long-term position but the other two
shorter term areas are we are going to
need to see over the next 20 years kind
of high rate of change of Technology and
yet we have standardization processes
and approval processes for new safety
measures and things which are done by
committee structures where agreement can
take many years to agree to a change and
if we're going to manage to absorb this
high rate of change of technology for
the benefit of mankind in the automotive
area we need to radically reduce the
time it takes us to get those brings so
we need new models and new processes
there and the third row exciting area is
going to be the impact the potential
impact of connectivity on things like
safety and congestion and the way we
drive and share our cars and that's
something we can look at immediately
because almost every driver whether in
the in the rich world or the rapidly
developing world almost every driver has
a mobile phone so thinking not about you
say about the very futuristic autonomous
vehicles but thinking now about the
radical effect that that connectivity we
already have can have in the next 10 or
even 15 years so some very immediate
exciting and beneficial in cups